こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんは取らんだとかね公園兄の映像とかっていう見たこと
あると思います例えばですね
映画のねちょっと感動するシーンとかいろんな音シーンがあるんですよ怖いし面白いし
笑えるしたまざまなシーンがあると思うんですけどもうなトッドは現在ちょっと af
をつくっていうことをしてるんでが操縦市民のこととかちょっと学んでいきたいと思っ
てない
で今日はちょっとある一つのシーンに絞ってほしいの中で何をして何を変えてどういう
表情でやってどういう服装で行ってどういる win 機とかでやればいいのか
いろんな音条件が重なって迫ねーよいろんな嬢ティング絡み合って初めてその映像作品
とかシーンっていうのができると僕は思っているわけなんですよ
なんで今日あの人
金を使って欲しいで様々なそのシチュエーションとか表情
クソ顔の動きとかいろんなものをチェンジしてて新言って誰が一番大事なんだかって
いうの猫の銅像として皆さんもね僕はちょっと学べばいいなと思っておりますね参考に
するシーンはこちらでどうぞ
俺は飯田天ぷらもすけ
サッカー部のキャプテンある日家のエースの田中が部活を辞めたメンバーのいない俺
だけサッカー部
グイン部族の危機だった
ni
おいらなぁ
皆ん
前
なんで参加もやレター
前には関係だろうざけんじゃねえ
なリスナー
お前のせいで先制機試合に出てるんだそう
運河ん
先生
それでこそ高田じゃあこれをちょっといろいろ変えてみてね色んなシーン
どうなんでやってみようと思いますどうぞよ
ん
ん ha
俺からカーン
お前
なぜサッカーをやめだなぁ
お前なら関係ねえだわけじゃねぇ
me
何するカラー
お前の正体スレ詩歌集に出てるんだぞ
何
先生ん
それでこそた仲だ
うん
car
おい誰だよん
me
お前
なんでサッカー部やメーター
はには関係ねーだろふざけんじゃねぇ
rar
に住んだよ
お前のせいで生成が試合でて言ってるんだぞ
ねぇ
それでこそ誰だから
ん
おいたラガー
eo ん
お前 f なぜ高めだ
はには関係ねーどちかげんじゃね
に住んだら
思えませんで全4試合に出てるんだろう
そんな
それ
それでいいかと田中だ
ん
分
ni
bel
終えたらカーン
飯田ん
お前
なんで参加をやめだ
前には関係ねぇだ
ザンギんじゃねぇ
何すんだよ
思えませんで先生がおっしゃるに出てるんだぞ
そんなん
再生
それでこそた仲だ
ん
うん
wh
ん
おいたらなぁ
犬ん
お前
ダメダメだなぁ
my dear 関係ねーだろんじゃねぇ
アリスんだよ
お前のせいで先生が主演で大変だぞ
うーん
戦前
それでも2中田
ん